[Musique]
le superbowl remportée hier par l'équipe
de kenza série le québécois l'horreur du
vernis tardif est une vitrine
exceptionnelle pour les entreprises on
vous présente ce soir deux de ses
entreprises
en voici tout de suite une première
pique ce mode de montréal entreprise
d'éclairage sans fil qui a fourni des
bracelets de faits de plastique recyclé
qui ont illuminé la foule au spectacle
de la mi-temps ont rejoint à miami le
président de picks up jean-olivier
d'alphonse bonsoir monsieur d'alfort
vous avez assisté au match à miami
comment décrivez-vous votre expérience
hier
fébriles on était avec beaucoup
d'anticipation pour voir le spectacle de
la mi temps
et lorsque ça a eu mais on a eu un grand
moment on avait vu les les général mais
quand on le voit les 65 m ghalem tout
d'un coup c'est une autre réaction alors
décliné nous se produit ce bracelet qui
s'est allumé justement à la mi temps
j'en ai réussi que je vais vous montrer
à la caméra oui on choisit grèce les ici
avec les couleurs du de l'habitat vous
voyez qu'il est noir comme ça parce
qu'il est fait de matériaux recyclés
c'est disney le soulier et des étuis de
téléphones cellulaires qui sont
déchiquetés et ça fait une couleur qui
ai un peu marre ont donc on rajoute un
peu d'huile de pigments noirs et ça fait
ce bracelet qui nettoie et donc vous
faites ça vous avez fait ça déjà au
super bowl par le passé n'est ce pas
avec le spectacle de bruno mars en 2014
exactement on était une toute jeune
compagnie en 2014
on a appris beaucoup dans les six
dernières années et là c'était notre
retour et je pense que ça a été un
succès et donc quelles sont les
retombées pour une entreprise comme la
vôtre
d'être présents comme ça un tel
événement d'importance tous les acteurs
du milieu du divertissement on regarde
le spectacle de la mi temps donc
ensuite lorsque les gens planifient leur
le monde se soit détournée que ce soit
des événements corporatifs ou
d'événements sportifs qui se disent
comment est ce que je fais en sorte de
connecter ma foule à ce spectacle que je
veux donner aux gens et les brasser les
mineurs oui ça crée de la lumière mais
je pense que ce qui est important de
comprendre c'est que ça crie du sont
sacrés du sont humains parce que
lorsqu'ils allument les gens et mettre
un cri qui je suis faire entendre dans
une dangereuse dans un stade dans une
arena qui fait une espèce de connexion
tout le monde
donc les gens reviennent vers nous et il
y aussi une légitimité et une
crédibilité ce sont des clients qui sont
très demandant ce qu'on aime
et ils sont demandant parce qu'ils sont
les meilleurs donc pas l'association les
gens nous font confiance et si ce qu'on
sait ce qu'on veut par dessus tout
qu'est ce que ça représente en terme de
préparation de participer à un événement
comme le super bowl pour vous je
voudrais c'est 20 % c'est de finir la
négociation avec le heat 80% c'est
l'exécution
c'est important on a une équipe avec
nous autres que ça fait plus de six ans
qu'on travaille sur des projets de cette
envergure là et les arrive on leur fait
confiance
et si beaucoup de gérer les 80 personnes
qui prennent des décisions quant aux
créatifs du spectacle que ce soit les
directeurs créatifs de shakira de
jennifer lopez
les producteurs donc on doit naviguer
autour de soi pour réaliser la vision
qu'il souhaite avoir
et ça fait partie des défis et aussi du
plaisir de faire c'est de trouver
comment réussir à faire le meilleur
produit le maire expérience votre
produit et fait donc de matériaux
recyclés pensée développée à montréal
même facturé en chine et vous récupérez
vos bracelets maintenant oui exactement
est en fait le bracelet que j'ai monté
un petit peu plus tôt c'est vrai cela si
c'est la première fois qu'on le mettait
sur le marché
c'est le premier événement qui a utilisé
les bracelets du club
je donne une petite anecdote c'était on
a fait la tournée des spice girls l'été
dernier et on avait une des chanteuses
geri halliwell
si ginger spice elle voulait nous parler
et comprenais pas trop pourquoi vent et
on se dit monsieur il ya trop classique
dans l'océan qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
alors on est resté un peu à se regarder
pour sidi alors tout à fait raison pour
cette tournée là il on était à quelques
semaines de la livraison dont comptons
utiliser les produits actuels mais on se
creuser la tête avec nos tripes on s'est
dit il faut trouver le futur
et ça c'est une partie de la réponse
avant ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on ramasse
des bracelets on en a ramassé plus de
1.5 million de ses draps séminaire sur
les tournées de telus aux fédérations
mendez
on est fier de ça par contre il faut
ensuite faire des bracelets que l'on
peut réutiliser est aussi fait de
matériaux recyclés et on a ensuite une
feuille de route avec différentes
innovations dans cette direction le
convoi mais de la mort dans les
prochaines semaines c'est très
intéressant on vous suit janvier
dalphond à miami ce soir merci merci